Don't Know Your Weapon X from your X-Men
no idea what a snicked is fear not
here's everything you need to know about
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine while X-Men
might have been a popular franchise for
Marvel Comics at the tail end of the
1990s comic book movies weren't exactly
in Vogue after the disastrous response
to 1997's Batman and Robin shook
Hollywood to its core the superhero
genre became Kryptonite for Hollywood
actors despite this sense of foreboding
many stars were linked to the part of
Wolverine at this time with some openly
throwing their hat into the X-Men
casting ring before Hugh Jackman grew
out his mutton Chomps and learned to say
bub Scottish actor dugres Scott was cast
as Wolverine and Brian singer's first x
movie unfortunately his work on Mission
Impossible 2 ran into overtime and he
was forced to drop out of X-Men by of
all people Tom Cruise Scott told the
telegraph in 2020 Tom Cruise didn't let
me do it we were doing Mission
Impossible and he was like you've got to
stay and finish the film and I said I
will but I'll go and do that as well for
whatever reason he said I couldn't he
was a very powerful guy instead Hugh
Jackman found his way into the movie and
the hearts of billions
the casting of Hugh Jackman is Wolverine
cut many people in the movie industry
off guard including the actor himself in
a later interview with Jimmy Fallon
Jackman revealed that his Wolverine
audition was only 20 seconds long at the
time he saw it as nothing more than a
box ticking exercise on the Studio's
part since dubray Scott had already been
cast in the role when I walked into that
room
I was pretty sure that I wasn't playing
the role but it seems that 20th Century
Fox wanted to hedge their bets do great
Scott had the role and then he got
caught up on Mission Impossible 2 but
everyone thought that would get sorted
but this year said look we need a backup
plan just in case Jackman explained that
this took the pressure off him during
his audition since he didn't believe
there was any chance he'd get the part
he just went with the flow Kevin feige
who was an associate producer on the
first X-Men film even offered to drive
him to the airport and get a bite to eat
the actor told him that he didn't have
to go out of his way to be nice however
as he knew the chances of him getting
the part were extremely slim and we all
know what happened next
Hugh Jackman has always worn his heart
on his sleeve when it comes to his wife
Deborah Lee furnace in an Instagram post
celebrating their 25th anniversary
Jackman wrote from nearly the moment we
met I knew our destiny was to be
together but Jackman and fernis aren't
always in perfect agreement in fact if
it was up to his wife Jackman would have
passed on the role of Wolverine in X-Men
the actor later told vulture my wife was
the one who said don't do it she read
the three pages I was given because they
wouldn't give me a script three pages I
got and she was like this is ridiculous
Jackman explained that they were both
confused by some of the comic book
terminology used such as the snitched
sound that Wolverine's claws make when
they pop out of his knuckles but Jackman
took the leap regardless of his wife's
apprehension in an interview with female
magazine Hugh Jackman admitted he knew
nothing about the X-Men comic book
series before he received the movie's
script however he liked what he read on
the page and could easily tell Logan was
a resonant character with enormous
potential but even though Jackman was
excited about the gig the people around
him tried to temper his expectations he
explained I remember several people
saying to me make sure you book another
gig before this thing comes out you know
try and use the leverage to get another
job because the word on the street is
it's probably not going to do great
business though this advice might sound
strange today these were the days before
the superhero boom changed Cinema as we
know it back then making a comic book
movie was basically a coin flip maybe
the people adapting the comics in
question had Vision passion for the
source material and the talent pull it
off or maybe they were simply trying to
cash in on a recognizable brand
fortunately the word on the street was
completely off the mark in this instance
in fact there's an argument to be made
that box office excessive X-Men is what
led to Hollywood's renewed interest in
superhero movies
Marine films the one that gets the worst
rap is X-Men Origins Wolverine directed
by gavinhood Origins earnestly attempts
to bring Wolverine's complex Beginnings
to the screen but many of its artistic
choices such as the treatment of
Deadpool and Gambit's tragic lack of
screen time left fans and critics
disappointed the movie might have been
doomed from the start however no matter
what creative decisions it made as an
unfinished copy was leaked onto the
internet more than a month before it was
released in U.S theaters speaking to the
media at the time Jackman remarked it's
a serious crime and there's no doubt
it's very disappointing I was
heartbroken by it the actor added that
Pirates Who downloaded the movie were
watching an incomplete creation which
simply couldn't be judged according to
typical metrics though this rough
version had already been watched by a
vast number of people before the film
arrived in cinemas X-Men Origins
Wolverine still managed to make a decent
373 million dollars off a 150 million
dollar budget in 2011 the mystery of who
leaked the movie was saw when a New
Yorker named Gilberto Sanchez pleaded
guilty to uploading The Unfinished film
onto the internet
there are no sacred cows in Deadpool the
first film in the series takes shots at
pretty much anything it can from its own
lack of budget to Wolverine and even
Hugh Jackman himself ah fake laugh
hiding real pain the franchise doesn't
stop there either if anything Deadpool 2
amps up the insults while it appears to
be all in good fun some people might not
take too kindly to being the butt of an
off repeat a joke but Hugh Jackman
actually loved these quips as Deadpool
co-writer Rhett Reese told Yahoo the
great thing about it is that Hugh was a
little bit like a guardian angel for us
he was very supportive of the movie he
was very supportive of us poking fun at
Wolverine Reese added that they brought
a number of questions to the actor
directly especially when it came to
jokes that used his likeness fortunately
Jackman found everything they suggested
hilarious and encouraged them to have
some fun at his expense
every Studio would love to sign an actor
up to play a superhero forever
especially if the money is rolling in
the truth is though actors usually want
to portray a wide variety of different
characters over the course of their
careers committing to a singular role
for a long stretch of time is a very
rare occurrence normally a contract may
be for a few years or a couple of movies
but even then Stars seem to count down
the days before they can hang up their
spandex Hugh Jackman is a notable
exception to this rule in his first
stint he played Wolverine for nearly 17
years eventually going out on his own
terms in Logan no one could fault him
for that after almost two decades at the
wheel it's a remarkable achievement and
a record-breaking one at that in 2019
both Jackman and Patrick Stewart
received Guinness World Record
certificates for having the longest
careers as live-action Marvel
superheroes and that was before both
Stuart and Jackman returned to their
respective roles when Hugh Jackman
retired as Wolverine for the first time
he did so on a high Logan is not only
one of the best X-Men films but arguably
one of the best superhero movies of all
time it's not surprising them that
nobody was really clamoring for Jackman
to go even before Logan blue fans and
critics away Jackman's Wolverine was the
most consistently high quality aspect of
a franchise that fluctuated wildly
between Brilliance and trash but Jackman
wanted to go out on top rather than
limped to the Finish Line in an
interview with Jimmy Fallon Jackman
explained that he once met Jerry
Seinfeld and asked the comedian how he
knew when it was time to pull the plug
on his long-running show Seinfeld when
you're creating something it's very
important not to run yourself dry it's
not about finishing on top necessarily
but making sure that you're creatively
still got something left the actor added
that he immediately went home and told
his wife that he was hanging up the
claws for good
in the world of comic book movies
there's just one certainty it's only
over if the money says it is yet James
mangold's Logan positions itself as the
final chapter in a legacy one from which
there is no going back and once the
movie was released it was made
abundantly clear that this version of
Logan was no more at a special screening
of Logan Noir Mangold and Hugh Jackman
revealed more about how they approached
the film for one thing their initial
discussions didn't actually cover
whether Logan would survive or not but
they felt they needed something
definitive to Mark the end of the
franchise and the character's story
Mangold said I wanted it to be like the
curtain has come down he told the story
just like a regular movie we're not
leaving something out there the story is
over
when fans learned that the X-Men would
be joining the Marvel Cinematic Universe
the rumor mill went into overdrive
regarding who would succeed Hugh Jackman
as Wolverine some fans thought Daniel
Radcliffe would be a good pick While
others swore only Tom Hardy should be in
consideration for the role there was
even a passionate petition for Danny
DeVito to play the hero I unzipped me
[Music]
their favorites and it's eager to make
their case even Jackman himself before
announcing his return for Deadpool 3
Jackman weighed in with his own choice
of actor for the iconic role speaking to
film critic Rajiv Mawson Jackman
suggested Indian actor Shahrukh Khan
should be a contender Jackman admires
the Bollywood performer enormously and
as it turns out Khan is a big fan of
both Wolverine and Jackman he praised
Jackman effusively at an Indian film
convention in 2011 and said his fellow
actor had once outright offered him the
opportunity to be part of an X-Men film
James mangold's Logan serves as the
perfect send-off for Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine it's raw emotional and
surprisingly beautiful fans flock to the
theater to say they're fun farewell to
one of the most iconic cinematic
interpretations of a classic superhero
while Jackman himself stated this was
the end of his journey as the old
kanucklehead so imagine the surprise of
comic book fans everywhere when Ryan
Reynolds revealed Jackman would be
returning as Wolverine for Deadpool 3.
once the celebration and chatter settled
many wondered what Mangold thought of
this since the director made Logan with
every intention of it being the end for
Jackman's Wolverine they didn't have to
wait long to find out Mangold posted a
gif of Logan's demise on Twitter without
comment leading the internet to draw its
own conclusion but he soon posted
another tweet clarifying there were no
hard feelings at all and that he
couldn't wait to see what his friends
would get up to in Deadpool 3.
[Music]